c'est une famille meurtrie et
terriblement affecté que nous avons
rencontré ce mercredi trois jours après
l'agression subie par son fils atteint
d'un handicap
impossible pour ces pères de famille
d'oublier la violence des images pour
l'huile très loin c'est un gros sur pour
lui comme pour nous donc j'espère que la
justice fera son boulot parce que c'est
une honte de devoir de faire des choses
comme ça de prendre un gain de moi un
gamin il a 22 ans d'accord mais de
frapper sur un gamin comme ils l'ont
fait ça c'est énorme et ça ne vaut donc
pas ça ça se reproduira pas et j'espère
face à la gravité de la situation la
famille a tenu à ce que les images
soient diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux
un moyen de partager l'information mais
surtout de faire en sorte que ces taxes
ne reste pas sans conséquences
maintenant on fait confiance à la
justice qui fasse le travail que ces
gens là soient pas impuni voilà qu'on
n'entende pas demain cette personne-là
appris que finalement trois mois ferme
et puis au bout d'un mois le sort des
gens parce que là on aura compris et on
recommencera tout le temps méritait pas
ça personne ne mérite ça c'est génial à
danjoutin les images de l'agression
forcément choqué et ému la population à
commencer par le maire qui connaît bien
la victime pour son implication dans la
vie de la commune c'est un jeune
effectivement qui participent beaucoup
tout ce qui est animations animations
communales mais aussi animations
associatif il est quelques associations
quand ils font leurs animations
la compréhension et la même du côté du
club de football où le jeune garçon
avait ses habitudes
il est là pratiquement tous les
dimanches maintenant un peu moins
puisque l'activité s'est un petit peu
arrêté au niveau associatif on va dire
mais autrement c'était quelqu'un a
effectivement en plus de très agréable
j'ai toujours courtois je veux dire poli
en tout cas au sein du club et il est
connu de tout le monde quoi en fin de
compte une enquête a été ouverte par le
parquet de belfort l'a déjà permis
d'identifier une seconde victime alors
qu'au total cinq personnes pourraient
être impliquées dans cette agression